No, it looks like I have some kind of connection with Takun-kun tomorrow hey
Nuts were good guys
see the
magic court notch color I
guess
this is what you're aiming for
magic court
If that's the case don't look away and look closely
this is you  But it's not even a small part of what we have to overcome from now on
This song is here
Tetsuhashi's younger brother The
longest magician who should have passed the school entrance It's
good to stand up
I didn't get it
[Music]
You guys were pretty interesting magic I was surprised Okay
, I have something I want to ask you guys
[Music]
What are these lithographs and jewels?
What were you trying to do with this? By the way,
you can't do anything with that magic.